we were free but we had no place to be
free
Lord help me reach my peace of the
promised land
protect me on this journey
do you want us we're all equals here
get on down
[Music]
I got him
this is what we're gonna do
I'm gonna get the sheriff and bring them
here I'm saying guard this being pole
guard him
Tommy Walsh
here we are you and me
guy open the horse
you know his white folk ain't coming
back
because they don't want to look at you
don't mean I can't see you'll always be
a slave to the white man
again
for what you did you ain't never gonna
hang wipe off
I had to learn as a black woman living
in this damn white world
that I gotta work three times it's hard
to get one-fifth of what I deserve
just go about it different ways
feel about it together
I didn't get a piece of my promise line
didn't get the river slow I'm milking
honey
pick what you deserve
buried out here
yeah
baby girl you're with dangerous water
you can be a hero
the glory of it Tommy Walsh and the
colored girl
what's my name
it's more washed
God damn that's not a headline here
before